[Music]
Los Angeles everybody want to be star
you have to be the best and never give
up and I can get up on stage in front of
people go like and think about is what
if they laugh at me you man you're
fearless I want to feel that too
I don't care I'll do it you only bought
how this dream yeah I guess we do that
we'll be famous we'll show them why shot
here we go to be or not to be it's not
gonna happen for you
not in a million years but after that
it's a town Greg they don't want me wish
we could just make our own movie a great
idea so there's this guy Johnny a true
American hero to be played by me he has
it all good luck my friends and also
maybe Johnny is vampire alleyway that's
right well why are we just shooting the
real alley because it's real Hollywood
movie no yeah okay action I did not hit
her I did not a high mark but the foot
doesn't work if you're looking at the
camera and then his good girl
anything for my pain cell
she betrayed him and then this gut
Johnny
he'd go crazy respect my busy Billy I do
this whole movie for you great but why
have you caught sandy this is great
that's real acting I'm gonna ride around
with the dress maybe do it before you
shoot yourself in the head of blow your
brains out I disagree I'm gonna make
this thing we are going to go together
[Music]
Tommy this is not necessarily very
necessary but I need to show my ass to
sell this movie I think you're handy I
am when I aim just do the scene why is
he having sex with her belly button he
knows were her vagina is right hi doggy
you